Ronaldo misses an open goal, and
immediately the questions start. Has he
lost his touch? Is it time to retire?
And how quickly the world moves on. One
moment you're a hero, the next you're a
clip or a headline or a debate that
people have. It's a well-known truth
about athletes, their glory has an
expiration date. Trophies gather dust,
and records get broken. Stadiums find
new names to chant. Eventually,
retirement comes, and with it, silence.
And then comes a second ending that no
one escapes. That's when the question
changes. Not how many goals did you
score, but what did you leave behind?
This is where Ronaldo stops being the
point, because the real legacy isn't
something that disappears when the legs
slow down, the crowds leave, or the
names stop trending. A real legacy is
something that continues to benefit
people long after you are gone. And this
brings us to a small village in Norway.
In this village lives a Muslim
community, many of them refugees who
lost everything to war. They escaped
bombs and bloodshed, hoping to protect
their children, only to arrive in a
place where they have no masjid, no
jummah, no space to pray together, no
space to pass Islam to the next
generation. For years, Islam barely
survived there. Until now,
alhamdulillah, the first and only masjid
in this village has begun. The five
prayers are being prayed in
congregation. Jummah is established.
Children are learning their deen. A
community that was slowly disappearing
now has a future. But this legacy is not
secured yet. To complete the purchase
and permanently protect this masjid,
$500,000
is urgently needed. If this succeeds,
Islam will remain in this village for
generations, [music] inshallah. If it
fails, everything is at risk. Football
legacies fade, and careers [music] end.
A masjid does not. Every salah prayed
there, every sajda, every child who
learns the Quran, every heart guided,
the reward continues to flow. This is
Sadaqah Jariyah. This is what it means
to leave something real behind.
Ronaldo's career will end. So will
everyone else's story in this world. The
only question is, what will still be
working for you [music] after you're
gone? This is your chance to build a
legacy that does not fade. The final
500K is needed now to secure this masjid
and protect Islam in this village
forever. Give whatever you can, whether
it's $100 or more, and be the reason
salah, Quran, and Jumu'ah continue there
long after you're gone. Click the link
and donate now and invest in a legacy
that will speak for you when you no
longer can.